THEY NEED TO ESTABLISH AND KEEP
THAT GOING.
ANTON LUNDELL
THIS COURT AT LEAST FOFO
PANTHERS WANT TO COME OUT REAL
STRONG, VEGAS SITTING HERE
WAITING FOR THREASONS WHY, THE
COME UP WITH A GOOD STEP IN
SPEED SO FAR, THEY KNOW, THEY
HAVE TO BE SCORING
CHANCES ON FIVE SHOTS, THEY
JUST WENT BY, BENNETT WAS RIGHT
THERE AT THE BLUE PAINT.
AND THEY ARE SHOWING
AGAIN EARLY TONIGHT.
LEONARD HAS MACAREFUL ABOUT THA
THE PANTHERS MADE THE THIS
IN THE ZONE, WHITECLOUD, GOT TO
COME BACK, LOOKS AT THE BOARDS
AND THIS TIME IT COME
THE BLUE.
HE GETS TO LUNDELL.
TRYING TO STRETCH PASS, NOT
PANTHERS HAVE THE  AT YOU. ONE.
VERY RARE FOR
WHAT A PLAY BY UP FOR AN EXCELL
>> Steve: VEGAS ON KNOCKED AWAY
SENDS ONE WHITE.
BENNETT. dy: COAST-TO-COAST WIT
BUTTERED TOAST  FROM
HE IS ABLE TO CLEAR THE ZONE.
PANTHERSNUMBER NINE, MEYER,
LOOKING, PUTS IT IN FRONT OF
SPENCER SETTLES THAT CLOCK DOWN
NOW LUOSTARINEN COULDN'T GET
IN. T
HIT HARD BUT DAYS STRONG ON
MARCHESSAULT
WEEGAR ROLLS IT
HIGH FOR VEGAS.
PIETRANGELO HAS GOT THE PUCK.
>> Randy: THE PURSUIT AND
HE MISSES ONE.4-1. AND THE PANT